this morning we're getting a rare look
at one of the world's most deadly
conflicts more than ten thousand people
in Yemen have died during a three-year
Civil War millions more are threatened
by famine and disease Yemen's government
is backed by Saudi Arabia it's fighting
rebel forces backed by Iran hala
Williams got access to war-torn Yemen
from the Saudi Arabian government to see
its version of the war these fighters
are taking us to the front line which is
at the top of this mountain range for
nearly three years Saudi Arabia has been
backing these Yemeni government soldiers
fighting a brutal war against Houthi
rebels who have seized swaths of land
yemeni general nasa Alva Barney told us
Saudi airstrikes are helping him win
back these barren Hills Houthi positions
are less than a mile away
have you lost family members have you
lost friends Holly Williams has left
Yemen and is with us from Istanbul
Turkey
Holly great reporting there based on
what you saw is there an end in sight
for this war in that humanitarian crisis
well good morning Yemen was already a
desperately poor country before this
civil war began but a Saudi Arabian
blockade has contributed to starvation
and a deadly cholera outbreak according
to aid groups eight million people are
on the brink of famine that's according
to the UN now we also met people who
said that they had been left homeless
and hungry by the opposing side by who
the Houthi rebels so this is a place
where both sides know that food or a
lack of food can be used as a weapon
well didn't the US and president Trump
pressure the Saudi government to end the
blockade this is a complicated story
Saudi Arabia is backing Yemeni
government forces in their fight against
Houthi rebels and the u.s. is supporting
the Saudi coalition with logistics and
intelligence this is a very nasty war
boy
sides have been accused of war crimes
but Saudi Arabia is supplied with US
weapons and it is capable of inflicting
much greater damage the Chowdhury
coalition has hit weddings markets and
schools with airstrikes according to a
UN report Gail all right thank you very
much Holly Williams reporting from
Istanbul